Welcome back everyone this is going to be my brand
new marvel doctor strange 2 video multiverse of
madness elizabeth olsen was talking more about
scarlet witch's special new abilities and powers
that they did not cover on wandavision so there
are even more deleted scenes that we're finding
out about now that we're supposed to set up some
new abilities that we'll see during doctor strange
2 so we'll break it all down it's all really
cool and things make a lot more sense once you
hear what she had to say about it but if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos i'll be doing videos for
this we have new loki episodes starting so we're
doing a disney plus giveaway for memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just let me know what you want them to
do with scarlet witch after doctor strange 2
kevin feige did say a long time ago that she was
one of the most important characters during marvel
phase 4. after wandavision episodes and after what
we've learned about doctor strange 2 now the plot
it actually makes a lot more sense why she's
so important but if you didn't see the last
couple of weeks elizabeth olsen has been doing
a lot of interviews talking about her character
as part of their big awards campaign it reveals
some special powers that scarlet witch has that
they just did not cover at all during wandavision
that aren't necessarily tied to her chaos magic
so the whole idea with the wandavision episodes
is that they explain what her powers are they
clarify that but she always had those powers like
she always had chaos magic she was born a witch
and everybody's wondering if that makes her a
mutant because she was born with powers being
born a witch isn't quite the same thing as being
born a mutant there's still ways that you could
explain that she's a mutant but if you want to
get really technical about it you really have to
be born with the x gene in order to be considered
a mutant but the whole thing with a dark hole her
being foretold as the scarlet witch of legend
that was always part of who she was we just
didn't know everything until wandavision they sort
of used that series to clarify all those things
the even bigger reveal though and this will
make more sense knowing about some of the other
wandavision deleted scenes that featured benedict
cumberbatch's doctor strange sort of involve his
character elizabeth olsen recently revealed that
scarlet witch also has the ability to travel
between universes at will she can travel the
multiverse just as easily as spider-man web
slings around new york city so what she was
talking about made a lot more sense when you
think about the whole nexus commercial during
wandavision episode 7 so here's where we get
into the deleted scenes that featured benedict
cumberbatch's doctor strange character i did a
whole video about that a little while ago so we'll
add a link for it in the description there was
originally going to be a lot more doctor strange
going on inside wandavision but originally they
were going to have doctor strange be responsible
for all the fake commercials that we were seeing
in the episodes and they were going to be his way
of trying to communicate with scarlet witch and
tell her what was going on inside the hex and
what was really going on with agatha harkness
and in the first five commercials the iron man
toastmaster the baron von strucker hydra watch the
hydra bath soap that was shaped like the tesseract
the paper towels to clean up all the blood that
she spilled oops the yo magic yogurt commercial
about agatha harkness stealing her magic all them
were based on the most significant or traumatic
moments in her life up to this point things from
her past for the most part but the last commercial
the nexus commercial seemingly didn't connect to
anything that she done previously like it wasn't
referencing earlier marvel movies and because of
these deleted scenes that we know about now
it was a much more overt example of doctor
strange referencing himself like talking about
doctor's prescriptions visiting the doctor he is
a medical doctor that's why he's called doctor
strange he's not a pharmacist like this doctor
here he's a surgeon but you get the idea all
doctors actually have the power of prescription
so given what elizabeth olsen said about scarlet
witch's ability to travel the multiverse at will
it seems like the nexus commercial was
also supposed to be a much bigger teaser
for doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness it
was also kind of meant to foreshadow benedict
cumberbatch's planned cameo in the wandavision
finale like a woman representing scarlet witch
was visiting her doctor who was helping her and in
the wandavision deleted scenes they were going to
have benedict cumberbatch show up and teach her
about her chaos magic powers and apparently the
commercial was also foreshadowing him teaching
her about her true nature as a nexus being which
is a huge comic book scarlet witch easter egg
that i talked about during a couple of my final
episode videos for those last few ones i think at
the time most of us saw that nexus commercial and
thought immediately it was meant to be a reference
to her as a nexus being like not only is a nexus
being a thing in marvel comics nexus also implies
a gateway of sorts to a bunch of different places
and because we're talking about her being in
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness a gateway
to the multiverse but nexus beings in the comics
are rare individual entities with the ability to
affect probability and thus the future thereby
altering the flow of the universal time stream
these beings each referred to as a nexus act as
the keystones of the multiverse and are crucial to
its ultimate coherence and stability doesn't this
start to sound familiar with the way they talked
about her in the background cosmic radiation
the way she was using the same type of energy
that emanated from the infinity stones to change
things at will change reality inside the hex nexus
beings are also vigilantly watched over by cosmic
forces such as the time variance authority and the
time keepers which we're going to meet on the loki
series so there's your wandavision loki connection
those forces like the time variance authority
watch for temporal changes that the nexus beings
might cause to the time stream and act accordingly
there are a couple rules that marvel created for
nexus beings as well only one nexus being is
supposed to exist on each of the parallel worlds
of the multiverse so that means one nexus being
in each universe they're supposed to personify the
character of the respective realm each serves as
a focal point or anchor to that particular reality
each being also acts as a node of mystical energy
for their respective world so immense amounts of
cosmic and magical energy mystical energy flow
through them which also explains why scarlet witch
is so bossed here powerful like the darkhold
says that she's supposed to be more powerful
than the sorcerer's supreme and for those of you
wondering if there are other nexus beings within
the mcu right now the other rules that they create
for these nexus beings in the comics is that no
two of them can actually be in the same universe
at any given time even if they're from alternate
universes if one nexus being wanted to talk to
a nexus being from another reality they'd have
to project themselves to speak to each other
it kind of seems like that's what's happening
in the wandavision post-credits scene with her
projecting herself into another realm because when
we first saw the scene everyone just immediately
thought that she was astral projecting but as we
saw with doctor strange when you asked to project
your body your physical body just shuts down like
an empty shell so instead of just simply astral
projecting yourself it seems like this is scarlet
witch actually using her different her separate
nexus powers this will also make a little more
sense too nexus beings also have the potential
to produce unbelievably powerful offspring
scarlet witch giving birth to building tommy is
a really good example of that we might see some
of this during the movie as well but also on top
of that they're supposed to be able to withstand
the greater forces of the universe and what they
mean by greater forces at least in the comics is
the greater abstract cosmic entities like eternity
which is the living embodiment of the multiverse
infinity death the living tribunal the phoenix
force so that would also explain how scarlet witch
could be bossed here powerful enough to stand
against whoever the main villain of doctor strange
two is going to be but each of the different
nexus beings of the multiverse is supposed to
have a power that's just unique to them that only
they have and at least in the mcu it sounds like
they're just using her chaos magic for that
like she is the only person who is capable
of wielding chaos magic unless someone steals it
from her like agatha harkness so for those of you
asking if loki is a nexus being in the mcu because
it's such a big multiverse series based on marvel
canon at least the way they explain nexus beings
it would be impossible because there can't be two
nexus beings in the main mcu universe a loki from
an alternate universe could be a nexus being but
he'd have to be born that way and if he were to
enter the main mcu dimension he'd have to be doing
it through astral projection or some other form
of projection he couldn't physically walk into
the main mcu universe and interact with the other
characters so i feel like this just confirms the
theory that scarlet witch just starts out at the
end of wandavision reading from the darkhold which
itself is extremely dangerous but then she hears
billy and tommy cry out and she's going to use her
powers as a nexus being to travel the multiverse
try to save them and the main villain of the movie
will take advantage of that and thus you have
chaos in the multiverse so that's where the title
comes from the multiverse of madness now there
are a lot of rumors about who the main villain
of the movie is but at least in the comics cathone
the god of chaos is the one who wrote the darkhold
that she's reading from and he's also the one
who imbued scarlet witch with her chaos magic
when she was being born but there was also a
report recently claiming that schumachorath
was going to be the main villain of the movie
he calls himself the lord of chaos and both he
and cathone use different magical books very
sinister magical books to try and trick people
into helping them re-enter the main mcu
dimension so that they can take over i
did a whole video explaining who schumachorth
is and what his history with doctor strange's
and some of the easter eggs that they included
for him in the first doctor strange movie so i'll
add a link for that in the description too if you
want to learn more about him he's more of an extra
dimensional being that existed in the void of
nothingness before the big bang kind of like the
dark elves from thor of the dark world before the
universe was created before the infinity stones
were created the other brand new character that
they introduced the last couple of years like
that would be null the god of the symbiotes
so it just sounds like scarlet witch reading
from the dark hold trying to find ways to bring
billy and tommy back just traveling to different
dimensions different universes at will looking
for them is where all the trouble starts in doctor
strange 2 and why she's so critical to this big
multiverse overarching plot of marvel phase four
because sam raimi's directing we can make all the
necronomicon references dangerous books that you
should never read from you mustn't read from the
book i believe that's actually from the mummy too
all kinds of just terrible books that you should
never read from it is a bummer that they wound
up not including a lot of these explainers and
deleted scenes during the wandavision episodes
i think part of the reason why they got rid of so
much of this stuff is because one they did have
some production issues with the virus lockdowns
but also because they didn't want the wandavision
episodes to get so over complicated that they felt
like glorified teasers for doctor strange 2 and
they just wanted it to be about wanda's character
development so i think a lot of that really cool
stuff they just decided okay we'll just deal
with this when we get to doctor strange 2
but let me know in the comments do you wish they
would have included all these cool explainers and
extra details in the actual episodes but speaking
of multiverse in related news there's supposed to
be a new spider-man no way home trailer sometime
in the next week or two so whenever tom holland
winds up leaking that footage of course i'll do
a video for it really hoping that the spectacular
spoiler man comes through for us in the next
couple of weeks my full loki episodes are going
to start posting in the next week or so as soon
as they start releasing them so make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you can be one
of the first people to watch those congratulations
troy bryant you're the giveaway winner from my
last big marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get your contact
details everyone click here for that brand new
huge spider-man no way home announcement that
marvel made about the future of the spider-man
character and click here for my brand new eternals
trailer video all about kit harrington's black
knight character thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!